stupid what am I giving let's have some
it's [ __ ] whiskey quarantine Monday
it's Monday yeah let's get this pigeon
drunk hopefully we'll keep some of this
well we'll keep some of the corona at
bay I do
I heard whisky and CBD oil cures corona
but only one kind of CBD is called pure
spectrum so weird
that's what governor who said that the
governor the governor's got together
youngers which one name what governor
they were like apparently you imagine
it's CBD actually cured corona you'd be
so wealthy yeah what oh hey hey and I
have to be like hey dude gotta see if
you gotta wet my beak all right cuz I
have information yes some dirt on me
I'm gonna wet your beak cheers brother
buddy cheers of the corona times that
are ending soon now a cup you'll find
this funny yeah so Joanna's cat died
she'll see this cat very much but the
cat died he was an outdoor cat he was
also 14 yeah
I'm not a cat guy so he passed the way
they decide to put him down so she was
all sad and she was mad cuz I wasn't
more open to how statua sand I went so I
was just trying to be again I'm a
numbers guy
you know wiseguy okay she came home she
was like super Samet
not area how old was she was 14 oh well
if it's like dog year she's really like
98 years old so it's time and actually
cats live much longer so that's a very
that cat was in bad health bad health
and you might have want to say now maybe
he's better you could have said should
have fed him better just to [ __ ] with
well here's an outdoor cat though you
know so they got my if I had Corona who
see how long the average cat lives he's
a riot cronies 14 sure so she's real sad
now I know I get that but let's just
think about this so once last time you
seen him she's like it's been mud so it
she wasn't that important if you haven't
seen him in months she was your
dick you're a dick that's fair though
actually two to 16 years in the wild in
the wild he was 14 a long time now now
and then I just got here you're saying
presents fresh in my mind so it was all
dark in our bed and she was sad and mad
at me and she like hit me and then she's
like you're such a I'm gonna [ __ ]
sleep was it cool and it's all dark and
I start singing the troll song
oh god what's the song they sing at the
end of trolls - it like just kept I kept
doing it over and over I've never heard
my friend right - no scroll scroll down
the new son no no not cast off the field
no God isn't the right scissor no it's
one of the puppet it's the original one
my buddy my buddy goes to uh gets in a
[ __ ] brawl with his girlfriend my
buddy Bob I got like a World War three
fight right oh this one I was thinking
thinking dark she she's crying I kept
going gone I see your true colors that's
why I love you so don't be afraid I got
this way shut the [ __ ] up you so
inconsiderate I went god damn I'm sorry
mr. McKee laugh hey - pause pause I see
your food it's the greatest that's the
greatest [ __ ] in the world I was
laughing so hard my buddy I mean show me
a picture the cat he's all that way
well yeah he died look at that cut did
you might have been [ __ ] patient
number one for Corona I'm not for me
I've told you that's the story about
when my my dog piggy died and my my wife
at the time she is so upset we weren't
even Maris's the people
this was my pit bull and so she's so
upset because my buddy we're on we're on
vacation and my buddy Andrew goes Brian
hey I have some bad news I go wedding
this piggy stopped breathing last
and I went ah you know I got a little
like that's my dog man and I went okay I
tell my my girlfriend and she and a man
is really emotional sight ma starts
crying she dad the dog for a year but
she she I did she loved it she starts
crying she goes you must feel so dear
about you my daughter I'm like I'm like
I do behind the eyes I did here's also
things that's what dogs do well that's
what they died they died I had a great
run with my daughter loved her so then
she's like weeping Saibaba so then her
parents are there with us we go to
breakfast and she's sitting there like
this and her father goes what's the
matter and she was piggy died and he was
oh and he's such a sweet guy my
father-in-law he drops his books and he
goes I'm sorry and hugs her right away
cuz I'm sorry sweetie the different
family for me my family not that family
this family he's holding her she's
crying yeah and so I'm like wow that's a
really a daring fanny
yeah and very comfortable and Moshe sure
so then we get home and piggy is on my
picnic table laid out very stiff and and
his tongue her tongue is sticky and dry
and I love this dog so don't I'm not
[ __ ] I am NOT incentivize humor my
dogs died you can find humor god I find
humor in dogs died but now I got it she
goes well were we gonna bury oh we're
gonna bury him on my friends property
it's been Canyon I go I go but but um we
have to put it I'd he was gonna smell so
I said I said I said I'm gonna put her
in a suitcase and she goes okay and
she's crying and I go where which
suitcase should I use the bill blass cuz
I don't know I guess the bill blass I
put the suitcase I go out drinking with
my friends we get drunk we go
you guys we got to give piggy a send-off
so we'll [ __ ] there one dude sober
take her to the sea take her to the sea
gets in the car drives me back to my
place she's sleeping in my little
[ __ ] bungalow in Venice I go let's
get her I bring piggy out I unzip the
thing I [ __ ] put her up and she's all
[ __ ] is there piggy and she comes out
put it back put it back you're being
you're being mean I'm like I'll God and
then long story short I take I take the
dog up the next day to [ __ ] Topanga
Canyon I'm digging a hole now
it's impossible deal it's impossible
Oh Noel does it I got that right if I
dig my own grave I'd get six inches
I gotta throw some dirt over me it's
gonna be a mouth just cover me and leave
I I couldn't find a soft spot plus it
was play I don't wanna make this so
tough dude I'm digging and I'm digging
I'm like well I got about a foot and a
half I go that's now I don't want to
touch the dog so she's like I can't look
and I I push the dog from the suitcase I
just go mmm
you hear boom and you just and she just
goes as she's living away she hears you
covered with the dirt yeah and then we
gave her I said a couple words to my
beautiful little doggy well she had a
great life and I did my good send off
man I uh I had a pit bull named Jersey
and college is my my dog in my brother's
she's a little pit that fierce dog just
a real fighting pit bull it really dude
nightmare when I'm at night without the
dogs right man when I moved to
California I left the dog with my dad
about three years ago my dad he's kind
of like the dog but she was kind of a
loose cannon and my dad does this color
I guess so yeah Jersey passed away what
her name is do I go why yes yeah yeah
you know she she was hobbling around and
we took her to the vet and they said
it's gonna be like $1,100 to fix it so I
put her down hey Joe exotic damn you put
the foot that died was like that's heavy
hobbling around you thinking I $1,100 I
went dead you could call me I would pay
for you guys yeah but she was suffering
oh well she like roller ankle she have
cancer yes you know what they don't know
see for me I Chi stimulated Joey's on
kill the Tigers well for me my dog got
cancer she would lie out she had let the
same dog when I came here was I it was
all Jews yes she's jumping up I was like
get this yeah so Lucy Gertie's held off
of me I rescued her from the pound and
she had very light skin some of those
dogs are kind of out buying [ __ ] it's
two and there mm and my exit the times
leaving the dog out in the Sun and I was
like I think we got to put sunblock on
the dog and I even said to the vet ago I
think I should with sunblock and that's
like well you'd be all right and I go I
don't know that dog lies in the Sun way
too much and doesn't have pigment in
parts of its skin sure enough skin
cancer skin econ's hair so I get ginger
uh-huh and so I I say
let's uh let's take that [ __ ] and
they we gotta take time ago we should
take the ear off I go alright I guess
take the ear off that's when I first met
you I jump over this ear was just
problem with that black answer and juice
yeah I was like jumping on me and she
starts slowing down I'm like what's
going on they do a thing and she had
cancer and put this thing in her body
and vehicle we could do chemo oh here I
go I'm not doing that to my [ __ ] dog
I ain't doing it to my dog I'm saying go
Papa cows not pay for this well by the
way that was five grand I don't have
money but yeah I had some money I didn't
write five grand back then down so I had
to slingshot on 1102 my dog rolled its
ankle I had to put it down hey man hey
when I wasn't making any money I had a
pitbull and I had a German Shepherd and
like an idiot you know what an idiot I
am I go I want a crazy a working dog
working German Shepherd I got it from
this special kennel and this dog was not
hearing it from any other dog and I was
one thing they'll scrapping like a
mother's locking up on each other $1,600
$3,600 I mean crazy damage I at one
point I was so mad at these dogs for
fighting I had to give one of them away
but I was so mad and the guy said
something like I would I didn't have
money I remember was something I was
gonna long vacation and I realized I
could choose vacation or I could choose
[ __ ] fixing my [ __ ] dog yeah
where'd you go Hawaii I I was going to I
I ended up paying the $2,300 yes and
learn all the stitches yeah I got to do
it yeah but I thought about it very hard
I really thought I thought mmm
all dogs go to heaven I put this [ __ ]
dog to sleep right now all dogs go to
head I was so mad but then I can't cuz
I'm gonna go stuff dude yeah they see my
dad killed my dog for $11 100 office dad
dad you got the money dog went down Oh
why'd you got the money
yeah stub your toe man it's a shame yeah
well my friend my friend is a farmer I
left my pitbull there for a little while
oh yeah several times you had to shoot
the dog
I know and guilty were goats
killed a baby calf it got loose and I
and all he says he goes BAM Bam's not
with us anymore turn right and pray for
dad how to shoot a sir that while he was
so mad yeah yeah you see you guys
right this wasn't same I'm speaking of
two colors my buddy gets a guess in a
world war three a fight with his girl
World War three okay I mean [ __ ] yeah I
ain't go to bed
they got a bet she gets in bed yeah
they're not gonna finish it yeah she's
she's doing this yeah so [ __ ] they
finally fall asleep so [ __ ] this then
she wakes up she starts moving around
again she gets up space matter she
farted no she pees she gets back into
bed oh dude like you know sure enough he
just goes hit her to the body he goes
like this he goes liver shot she's lying
must keeps moving around he goes in this
corner Vegas in that corner [ __ ]
Johnson just [ __ ] body slams her oh
really
yep that's domestic violence bro it sure
was but then you know they started
fighting just to get a [ __ ] off me and
then after oh yeah make up sex after he
did the wiggler [ __ ] crusher and then
she's like got me be serious I'm gonna
crash out and I can't get off yeah I
gotta crush it you know wiggler and then
hey look at me sure enough Paisley
[ __ ] was your friend named Bryan
Callen with a shitty haircut no but it
but I've done that before yeah dude this
call this quarantine we're gonna mr.
Trump's got to release the hounds mr.
transmission to me some good news
thanks and good news sounds like New
York which has been the epicenter of
just the worst conditions New York New
Jersey Connecticut taxes are all gonna
start opening things back up so our
[ __ ] [ __ ] governor Newsom is gonna
the pressures gonna be on him yeah and
when Trump said hey up I'm about to make
some changes and people like it's up to
the governor John when he actually
addressed it in his tweet with no no you
guys keep saying that the governor has
all the power here if I say open back up
those [ __ ] open back up yeah
because the federal wall right federal
it's important budget at least 14 - you
stupid flop but there's a lot of like
talk about how we are people think that
when you're when you want to open things
you're insensitive to people dying
you're insensitive to the situation no
I'm not [ __ ] no I'm not I get it
there are people that have underlying
health conditions there are people who
are old like my parents I don't want it
I don't want to do anything that is
irresponsible with my behavior that's
why your parents should stay quarantine
that's an old stay the [ __ ] and I do
think that this stay at home order has
been appropriate I'm not an
epidemiologist in part of it because
because we don't we just didn't know so
the one thing that I've talked to
actually believe it or not to
epidemiologists don't ask why and how
well I know it's not I really did I
talked to two
one of whom was actually somebody who
goes all over the globe and does the
hazmat suits a real badass right she was
really worried about it and the reason
she was really worried about it was was
because they just didn't know enough
about it but also it's a really
efficient virus because it can incubate
maybe 70% of the people are asymptomatic
but they can still pass it on so that
can be a problem right if you have that
a lot of old people out who originally
you would have over on hospitals yeah I
like to flow yeah but I it's working it
is different it is different so we have
to be sensitive Lou kills more but yeah
sure you know when I went back when I
went bad and standby it on on [ __ ] you
know Garcetti asking me to snitch on my
neighbors I'm going back on that
principle oh I want to piss on I don't
care sometimes you have to say yes this
might make people safer in overall but
you have to you have to weigh your it's
exactly like with terrorism it's the
same debate you have to weigh personal
freedom and what makes this country
great
with over reactions that can take away
yours no doubt dude and you know why you
know I'm lighter shirt you know what
neighbor's [ __ ] turn-on you know it's
weird is this this whiskey tastes like a
young japanese man pissed in my mouth it
tastes awful you don't like it I don't
do you like it if I see I'm spoiled with
the with the other stuff I [ __ ] up
because they didn't send in time so is
it got a little whiskey for the boys for
the crew cat included and it tastes like
a young teenage smooth tastes like a
young teenage Japanese man is pissing in
my my tastes a little bit alcohol yeah
it's not it's not nice it's just not
smooth it tastes a little alcohol you it
tastes a little taste like a young
Japanese man ate a bunch of a spheric it
smells a little bit like I'm pissed in
my
it smells a little bit like bad tequila
you wanna try some gin
after that well no well Brian likes it
you wanna try to you're a whiskey
drinker right yeah yeah try some here
Kat give this to channel thank you
finish that bad boy real fast
oh damn you know you and your girl yeah
because we're just sitting inside doing
nothing Jesus it don't put anything in
front of me right now with what a
massage don't put cocaine mushroom
nothing I might do it all the young
black men don't really sing in front of
me oh wait what would you say I would
sit while I was playing no you were
playing that other thing but yeah yeah
young black whatever whatever you put in
front of young black out with a positive
attitude don't put them in my house in
front of my house something it loose I
might get loose don't put anything near
me finally learning pictures of my deck
to friends like yourself did it's so
funny I don't know what else to do your
dick on you I got a good dick on me
sometimes I said well he's back at it
and it's just a picture of Brian
standing there with his dick out he's
back at goddamn it dude hey what did I
tell you this I told you I told you
about how I took the manscape or to my
yeah yeah yeah and I don't really have
any pubes yeah as last show big girl
yeah it does look thick now granted we
made funnier here pretty hardcore and a
lot of people did online lot chicks dig
it my huh I've been getting a lot of
female fans telling me that they like my
hair every female fan loves it every
male fan hates it well I don't think
they hate it it's just easy to make fun
of
that's one cat when I walk I've been
crying you look good today when he looks
good today again cat appreciate your
positive attitude way to bring that
today here's the thing though cat short
she's looking up like this she can't get
through the [ __ ] show at the top you're
looking down and she doesn't see that
you look like Jason Statham shitty older
brother
yeah no I'm saying there's a little bit
about your getting a different angle see
it all depends on what angle you look at
somebody for I get all in haven't you
dated girls where they look amazing from
one angle and then you seem from another
and it's like oh no a Sun hits their
face and they look like [ __ ] Hulk
Hogan had a beard problem I had that
with the you know I'm talking about I
don't
I saw a certain actress who I used to be
obsessed
and I saw her from the side I think we
talked about this but she had a mustache
like a monster 1997 saw my very pretty
hugged Iran if you see her from the side
hater show her from her chin no I gotta
be a god bless her very beautiful very
sexy she's just got a straw like a
strong chin and I do too and I thought
damn you know what right here there
right here looks a little a little bit
Irish if you saw it was short hair short
hair and that it was it was an
unflattering look like short hair
otherwise she's gorgeous she should and
I'm being wrong goatee I would yeah I
don't like being mean he's so hot yes
she's course I'll dude her and [ __ ]
dust till dawn Oh Santa when I was a
young strapping lad I would Jack it to
that thing she's beautiful I like that
gender I like everything about her I'm
just hate her I'm just saying for me I
have I I have a specific now I saw on
that leap Ortman with a shaved head and
I would walk over what is that been that
bad I don't know it's just like show
stop look at her they're smoking look at
that scene of all time lebanese mexican
then you get that thick snake around her
neck that's a good movie i wanna watch
that it doesn't hold up have you watched
it lately
mm it's pretty cheesy she's so [ __ ]
bad oh yeah oh and there's a vampire oh
you're wrong
I see it doesn't hold up it's a little
cheesy but man is it good it's
entertaining
she's those are everything about that is
real she's so delicious yeah but no you
don't know you said her face is funny
sign of whatever well just from a
certain angle when she was doing Frieda
with that hair Madeleine of course
Frieda was a unibrow no problem Darwin
she was shooting that though so I either
hate her would you do for bunny day um I
I pushed a sled a weighted sled too far
and for too many times as necessary did
for your workout I took my kids
there you go Bobo to have to an empty
parkour gym we jumped on professional
trampolines offensive line and learn
a little bit about parkour I was gonna
offer that to you and little tiger and
he would love it we do go we can go this
week we can go this week because it's
completely empty and in the way that the
owner does it is that we don't touch the
door
we only it's like like my kids in your
kids yeah I don't do that I will lick
that door handle yes and you know I got
tested for Corona and you are don't have
it
it was my girl you've never had it I
never had it it checks if you've had it
or ever had it nothing
all right so anyway these this this is a
professional parkour gym and the kids
[ __ ] love that they're stir-crazy
well I take them will migrate for build
or do stuff I think you they have
five-year-olds there that take class
I'll be able to do so sure so as you
play sock with the six and seven year
old they they they they will lose their
mind terribly you can just jump on the
trampoline yeah Mike Mike son my my son
can do it all day he just he never gets
tired of it
satisfied your boy your boy feel came
over for he saw I was inviting mine
holidays but I don't have any family
here yeah so he came over for Easter
he doesn't realize that TT is full of
energy
he's 24/7 and he likes to wrestle
everybody that comes through that
goddamn door well that's his grandpa
whoever it is yield wrestling
feels not that much of a physical person
a kid person probably no he's not bad
he's really good with he's really good
with Tiger but Tiger will chunk the [ __ ]
out of you so Tiger does back and most
yanked his wig off really you just not
stop he's crazy
it's like damn it's what kids are like I
know this for me like that Walt Tigers
different breed dude Tigers I go TT
seals not gonna play with anymore cuz
you're too rough you're just too rough
dude you're rough with everybody just
Papa were rough like we are rough he's
never won the ball got thrown on his
face really hard by accident and he
didn't cry and every other kid would cry
with that you did that to my son now at
18 strike how about he rode his bike
with me three miles wide three miles
what three miles at four four years old
three miles didn't walk didn't stop
three miles crash loves that he loves
that hike loves it
I'm gonna come up yeah
and what this week yeah that's amazing
um I push the sled like I was saying I
did a workout sometimes you can push
yourself too hard at 53 and then the
next day you got some big problem it was
the sled up it was at the parkour gym oh
and I pushed it and then I would
alternate between that deadlift and
benchpress oh there's like a full gym
there huh that's cool all right like a
CrossFit gym and so I'm always set up
first this week well 100% he actually
offered it I'm strong I'm dense I'm sore
problem would be my age when you work
out really hard as you have trouble
walking the next here's the thing seven
days to recover for you it does yeah
your old your recovery and also pop up
be here I'm not I'm gonna check in
anymore at 37 Brian that bike up that
mountain like I do and I crashed
yesterday I've never been sore ever in
my life my legs nothing I've never been
this sore really from that bike running
I'll do my legs are it's so fatiguing
dude it's well the hardest thing you
ever taken a week off exercise ever
never in your life diver never again
eight seven days a week how long have
you been doing that
I can't dine we can tell you literally
like since you for second remember since
I was a kid you never stopped ever
that's why you're so [ __ ] strong yeah
maybe
and also why you never really got
injured and ever get hurt I don't take
any time off even if it's something
light so so when you do have you ever
had a shoulder issue or anything like
that an hour riding I have to get a
cortisone shot my shoulder but since
then no you just keep working out you
work through it non-stop that must be
the secret
maybe Wow seven days a week you don't
take a day off mm-hmm really never so is
there a light day that you'll do what do
you do light day be like like two
classes on the peloton like that peloton
bike so easy for me now light day is two
classes who class light day yep so it's
Stern quarantine holy [ __ ] yeah
back-to-back or you just pace it out
space it out one in the morning one that
how long are those class 45 minutes so
your cardio is something else right
cardio is employ right now
I'm still on chinoe I'm below the belt I
love Matt mountain-bike I'm obsessed
with it because there's a bit of danger
to it like when I'm going down you
better watch your P's and Q's gonna die
and I don't have anything like that in
my life like I don't really do jiu-jitsu
anymore I don't I don't box I don't spar
I'm not fighting
football's dangerous so I don't really
have that I get nervous doing stand-up
it's not life-threatening Jim I saw you
missed you Jitsu so yeah I have an
apology I need to make an apology to
jujitsu people everywhere when I said
that smaller dudes are always at a
disadvantage against big dudes like that
some of the jujitsu people sent me I
sent you that that video of that one I
don't know why you argued me on this
stuff it's like New York and Paul to be
like this feel like what to be is that
strong but bubblin I don't know I I now
whatever you've studied I've been
engulfed in that world for years I just
thought you were being like politically
correct if you will
no you know what I mean I thought you
were done being a little bit like no not
at all yeah I have no reason to offend
you yeah I don't know why you argue with
me I'm people were sending me [ __ ] of
like giant black belts who were
competitive against like world klesko
that guy that a Bravo 10th planet guy
who was part of a freak brother calm
this [ __ ] I was just like oh my god
me I that I but I've lived that dude so
when you argue me I'm like I'll [ __ ]
yeah you've lived it with all I don't
know why you argue I'm a guy I don't
yeah I know you did like two years at
handles well can I be honest with you a
lot of us because I've seen you take
world class guys who are smaller and
completely neutralized you haven't but
you've also seen me you you you've on
again here nod you're also been that's
after you've been training for ten for
eight years I was a professional athlete
yeah your lot just doesn't make sense
right and wrestler and you've been doing
it that long
yeah so it's different instead but also
you've also seen been in there when
hunter and here on role me the [ __ ] up
yes I'm Way bigger those guys yes way
big yes that is you were there when they
[ __ ] me and Leo machito up in the same
room that is correct don't you remember
you never remember it very well and in
fact Henner started on his back I talked
to him and destroyed when I went that's
like you slim Leo's I was like oh you're
ahead of them he's heady but but he's
also six five and long
so much lighter than me yes I am I 60
pounds at least
yeah that's 180 pounds that's not a good
example though cuz he's he's big enough
to be beat anybody I mean he's long and
he's he's still a hundred eighty now
yeah your argument a smaller guy a
bigger guy could neutralize that well
that mean then like you said with T City
who would you say would just wrap up you
know so many people who were huge huge
again but I've seen it I'm here I've
lived that life see so your argument
it's almost I'm just like alpha I don't
know I just was like [ __ ] III again
it's because I got I saw you and your
strength and just taking guys who here's
the problem with that you're assuming
because I'm stronger I'm beating them no
you're something course you're a did you
Jersey at 10 years yeah guys in the UFC
yeah every still you're taking that yeah
and saying oh no big guys can neutralize
jujitsu debt it's at T cities girl
I'm on a date with her I don't know but
she's been the most desired girl in a
while who is she
Valerie Loretta this is advice for
Bellator super Bobby though god bless
your pictures yeah I do
I certainly do buddy I was here playing
with little puppy oh well she's she's
the hottest girl in MMA without a doubt
there's heard probably dancing it's got
a little yeah I mean if you're into that
if you're in a small waist in perfect
fascism it's ridiculous and she fights
yeah high-level fighter yeah yeah man
schism there's a with one of her friends
what's going on what is coming up Jenner
I'm saying though what's going on
got the comet why are you outside [ __ ] I
hate [ __ ] I mean she's uh she's just
a straight-up dimepiece who decided to
get a punch in the face for a living
well I can't have her getting punched in
the face I will save her right now what
are your bills girl is that is that Maas
Vuitton yeah eighteen easy with the
rumors easy
I'm not saturating the training partners
that's that's training partner okay god
she's right John oculus
she's redonkulous good for her I know
talk about marketing do you know I can't
get enough of the Ozark great show
oh let's see there it is Jason Bateman
right it's a great show you're on season
3 already I've only gone through season
one gets better yes season two's good
everybody's been telling me everybody
I've been getting from my cast mates
from school they are they also did a
bonus episode on Tiger King our Bowl our
boy Joel McHale host of it Oh Joel
really but it's all like FaceTime with
all the characters I hate FaceTime
interviews and [ __ ] Joel did the best he
could he's pretty funny on there but
it's just I would say we're all in a
room together because I wanted the chaos
there saying Joe exotic he's always
wanted Fame and he's like the most
famous person on earth right now but
he's locked in a cage they're saying the
irony of it
how about he admitted to killing those
Tigers the healthy Tigers in prison he
admitted oh yeah but didn't weren't they
sick or something no that's when they do
it they're like he said they weren't
sick he just needed the space so he
killed these healthy Tigers Sean he
called him up the cage and shot in the
face in the head I shouldn't say face
yeah that's what happens when you have
300 Tigers and it cost $300,000 a year
or something to feed him but here's what
attention everyone them some of them
were his friends they all go does he
deserve to be in jail every single one
of them said yes every single one go yes
yeah he's a lot of bad things yeah he's
a bad guy
yeah it's a bad guy yeah he's [ __ ] yeah
he's awful and the people around him
were not awful they were kind of they
were not bad people it seems how about
how about his boyfriend the one with the
meth teeth he has all new teeth now good
for him he has a fiance who's out who's
a girl yeah he's not gay that's right
he's just messed up oh he's a
good-looking guy excuse me well with his
teeth line all right
the good-looking guy it's not a
bad-looking guy yeah with T and then
he'll massage Doug Lee you're not
getting Oh teeth I mean not good if you
cover his mouth he's not a bad-looking
dude
in fact he's beautiful
beautiful guys we gotta not have that
beard over here so tall that he's got
terrible ideas of what the good looks
good on his face no like no teeth I was
Dennis dear dusting here's what's
interesting to that one kid who
committed suicide they came out said it
wasn't suicide suicide by accident he
had a gun he's messing around you didn't
know there's one in the chamber and cuz
the guy who actually saw him commit
suicide
said he's messing around didn't know his
chamber and he pulled it he said for
about five seconds saw the look in his
eyes like oh [ __ ] died maybe how he or
he killed himself
you know we don't know well I mean they
would say it this this guy came out was
like no I saw it not from the expression
in his eyes after a bullets got in his
head you can't tell that's you gotta
watch it because it came out that his
accident but yeah I hope it was I mean
if you wanna play this tiger so bad he's
willing to suck dick there must be a
great deal to do who is that guy
which one Geoffrey Charles Djou second
husband I don't know another this people
sent me crazy [ __ ] that Jo exact used to
make people have sex with the Tigers and
all sorts of ones that they're not
possible you'd be surprised on boy
really yeah what do you do push your
[ __ ] against the cage and put sardine
oil around your hole how do you get a
tiger to [ __ ] you you [ __ ] the tiger and
homeboy love that tail good luck with
that I'm sure tell they're awfully
sedated dude oh he's not hanging to it
dude what about [ __ ] Tiger Joe exotic
man yeah what about that other guy which
one Jeff oh he still run the zoo Jeff
love is that zoo overrun now with
[ __ ] sightseers and people they must
be making a for war in quarantine right
so I can't go out in there shut down but
I hear where you're going well is uh so
they were so I I thought you weren't
allowed to are you not allowed to breed
tigers anymore is it still allowed did
that I don't yeah I don't know cuz
apparently they're all pieces of [ __ ]
when you talk to the one guy he goes now
you know all these people and they all
run these lion or tiger sanctuaries
is Carol is it Karen Baskins Caravan
Cheryl Cheryl bastions he was she
actually helping people you just stop
they're all the same they're all making
money off these poor Tigers all the same
it's all [ __ ] show yeah she was they
just cover at different ways here's all
the same of course Travis the 9-piece
who went to play with Tigers so bad suck
dick such a bomb that's a bummer
apparently Joe exec has a bunch episodes
on YouTube unis watch heard they're
fascinating heard they're been in the
documentary she's just some wild [ __ ]
Travis dresses Deborah Joe attic oh he
does he used to have a youtube channel
and there's a shitload of stuff on that
have you got overlooked or chin I saw
that that's where I found a music video
I'm not sure if I saw his actual YouTube
or his music YouTube yeah I don't know
you know his boyfriend Iman said he
definitely wasn't singing those songs
that's hilarious
that's so funny man guys Joey doc TV and
I think that's where all the videos
100,000 subscribers that mean blew up
recently for sure this is the biggest
documentary of all time believe that is
it really I think so well that's what I
kept saying do you think of it well
making a murderer that was pretty big
yeah but Tigers are yeah was fast
well Joe exotic [ __ ] the time the Tigers
the Tigers yeah he's been a million
tiger you have amazing characters an
tigress you have Joe exotic dude yeah
he's the he's such a witnessed here in
our system Jay boyfriends husbands
chillin Tigers you learn all these
meters trying to kill other people I
wonder how you can figure out the
biggest documentary of all time holder I
wonder what would compete with that I
don't know there's been some great
documentaries man like because Netflix
doesn't release any views or anything
well they do you have no idea how you're
special does Oh Chris Dula special drops
tonight at midnight
sweet kids probably watch it tomorrow
morning tonight at midnight I'm sure
this is not recent though
50 most of you but Netflix won't give
them them yeah there's another problem
too going clear was a big one
foodie Inc was huge this is 50 tosser
these are faked this is [ __ ] these
are 50 documentaries that these dorks
watch and may decide about you know what
I can find out though I don't know weird
Netflix um release any numbers like if
you shot a special on there and let's
say you went from doing clubs to arenas
you like well I'll see a shitload of
people watched it yeah you'd like to
know those numbers yeah they don't tell
you no Tigers apparently Tigers are much
safer to work with then chimpanzees
lions why because Lions have hurts and
tigers are by the rods yes and birds but
less they hurt they don't have hooves
but prides and a pride of lions
apparently lions are very intelligent
because I have to read social cues from
each other and their hierarchal they
have heads so so when you come in and
you got a limp or you come in and you
got you know you're not you're not
giving them like solely heat this guy
who trains Tiger says when you bring
people in the cage you let the tiger
greet you you let the tiger do his thing
and it's like well I mean I'm sorry lion
greet you because the Lions are very
cute and socially they're very cute into
what you're doing and the kind of
signals you're giving them
where's Tigers are not that way and
they're different I don't want to be
around in these [ __ ] animals I I'm I
just never touch why I feel like it's a
matter of time before you're gonna get
[ __ ] you know something's gonna happen
doesn't make sense to me nope it doesn't
but there's something amazing about
danger that's why human beings like to
why do you climb k2 we're one in four
people die why tires are the same thing
you the juice of it the feeling of I'm
the only person that can do this I'm
gonna be down to climb k2 I wouldn't be
down to [ __ ] [ __ ] nice the guide the
[ __ ] guy's got a king cobra as a pet
king cobra as a pet let me say pet guess
what he you what happens is you go the
guy knows snake after for three years
after a year whatever I'm comfortable
around saying I'm I now to pick it up
and I'm comfortable you know what I'm
casual chip app bite you the guy goes
well I'm gonna put the caged snake back
in I'm gonna go I'll just drive I'll
Drive myself to the [ __ ] you hear him
on the thing he goes I got bit by a king
cobra had to pull over I can't see I'm
going blind I need something that's
right another woman she got bit by a
king cobra same thing
she's a herpetologist she goes MA that's
crazy got bit
she puts the snake back in she takes
care of some things around the house
before she goes takes care of some
things
dumbest then decides the driver she died
well she died of the venom yeah because
there's that one kid who committed
suicide he worked at a pet shop and he
got all the dangerous snakes and
released him in his car
I thought commit to he did yeah come on
yeah what the Faust thinking about him
the other day for some reason well
that's a guy's terrible way to go I the
teenager who broke into the DC zoo in
the 80s and stole two gaboon Vipers
bring up bring up on Vipers the kid that
kill himself oh it's so sad oh suicide
by snake let's see what kind of snakes
it was he was only 18 Cobra from the
exotic pets a Cobra dude now if you have
to release everything and then make sure
they bite you yeah Cobras will really
[ __ ] you up I think they have a blood
and nerve toxin you're right multiple
snakes in his car our multiple
snakebites stories found a snake
tarantulas and cobras [ __ ] would that be
a snake though oh my G separate Cobras
from man oh man oh man well this kid is
stole bring up gaboon Vipers go boon
it's the biggest Viper in the world
Oh God there he stole two and he put
them in a and a burlap potato sack slung
them over his back they got on the bus
there you go now their fangs could be
two inches long they are there are this
thick Brennan no dislike you know this
makes that thick you gotta see how thick
their odds crazy they are the biggest
snakes they have been known they
believed to kill elephants small
that's when they bite him that's that's
how crazy there look at that thing
the thing looks cool though yeah thick
is [ __ ] he took two of those threw him
over his back ladies and gentlemen
over his back the gaboon Vipers were
like well this is burlap I'm gonna bite
through the burlap if you don't mind
bit him in his back and he became
paralyzed if you don't wanna die
nope just realize you did become
paralyzed though cuz your your back you
know the nerves is that short fat dicks
name yeah that's you get that short fat
dick it's like a bone Viper snakes look
so [ __ ] vicious yeah those especially
and they blend in with the leaves well I
think about snakes I'm riding my bike
man well those and they don't rattle
that's just so fives hit you there's so
fat fish it's a short that's why they
called you got that short fat snake
oblong yeah yeah girl take that Gabon
yeah yeah take that Gobbo I know it's
short fat haulage I enjoy the short fat
yeah boom snake apologize he's got out
spirit with this snake bout to spit big
he thick sharp eye you bad you got a
case of the Gabon oh he just one girl
he's spinning I've got boon you got a
case the old guy boo boo this guy Boone
spits girl oh yeah sorry about my kaboom
yeah boom he's got a serious case of the
gas bragging rights venom yield of any
snake next to the king cobra well there
you go bruh still King yeah there you go
that's a big old shot of venom out like
that boom snakes ugly Oh Africa Africa
of course where they come from
horse Africa that's the heart of Africa
look in the middle of that right in the
middle of the Congo right there I think
I know Africa so big says my god woman
like that Boone's ugly man short fat so
those fangs
it goes out here are those two fangs it
looks like for a double an angry for if
you just put on the wrist to do damage
man huh terrifying yeah I just don't
like snakes men
oh there's Vidya one for the studio saw
a video these dear smelling Oh bring out
that that a truly giant snake packing
venom they bring up I don't even see the
guy guarantee as a ponytail whoa whoa
whoa this guy make today awesome make
today awesome awesome
Dolan's points out ponytail they always
are these are the kind of guys that
there's the gobble my breath
I just grab that fat snake like the odor
quichua apparently they're not
aggressive yeah apparently not
aggressive dude he is so thick yeah dude
they're putting them in a sack - yep
that guy went ponytail and mustache they
go right to sleep
fire yes I'm kind of helps Jen yeah yo
Brian there's no way on the planet like
you man so why would you buy a generic
mattress built for everybody my body is
my body and it's very unique and I need
a mattress here's my problem in a
mattress that can read my contours read
the way I sleep because I sleep in a
unique way
do you know Felix and why you like to
sleep was even award the number one best
overall mattress pick of two a 19 and
2020 by GQ and Wired magazine whoa dude
you got back pain what do you got I'm a
member I'm a hot sleeper and I like a
plush bed but sometimes I like a firm
better I got you say no more my friend
just go to helix sleep calm slash
fighter take the two minutes sleep quiz
and they'll Matthew to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep ever they have a 10 year warranty
and you get to try it out for 100 nights
risk free try it out don't even pick it
up dude I'll pick it up pick it up but
you're gonna love it
helix is offering you guys 200 hours off
all mattress orders and free pillows for
the final kid listeners helix sleep calm
slash fighter
that's helix sleep calm slash fighter
for up to 200 dollars off I like it
oh dude what'd you think of the USC game
canceled your boy the governor is the
one who canceled it you know that do you
know that your boy they see it what
happened was
it was like oh here's the problem it's
not a central business and if we let
this happen then we gotta let other
things happen we know about this now
gotta shut it down it's kind of like it
would be unfair to let you guys do this
when we're shutting down all these other
things that's kind of the idea I would
imagine because they got to be
consistent otherwise they'd take heat it
sucks it sucks cuz I would argue that
that's entertainment and we're all at
home we'd all like it here's what's in
this Disney and ESPN was down they knew
what Dana was doing we were I know when
governor Justin came in and was like you
know they can't do this then Disney is
like [ __ ] hey Dana I can't do this and
then Dizzy's like yeah we're onboard
with you man it's really bad to do this
like what the [ __ ] guys weren't saying
that last week yeah yeah yep I like to
throw it yeah boom Viper with Newsom
right now well you know not kill him
just like Mike Mike from what I
understand about Gavin Newsom is he's
looking at worst-case scenario my only
issue is this and I'm not being cynical
do you think it's possible that
governor's like him are trying to first
of all we apparently he's done a pretty
good job because our cases in California
we have have had the explosion that was
predicted okay so that's good news you
wonder at times if if he is being overly
zealous about this so that he at the end
of the day can say look at although my
numbers are and that's a dance with the
devil but you know what's the dance the
devil the economy economy computer
cockpit right so it becomes this thing
you know that's very sane I like them
before all this to men I kind of replica
should we hear this or no yeah okay I'm
not sure we could play it on plays I do
a joint statement of a shared vision for
a process and protocol a framework we
refer to it for reopening not just
within our state's but more broadly as a
region I don't want to overstate this
vision I don't want to overstate this
framework and I don't want to understate
the imperative of meeting this moment by
continuing to
practice appropriate social distancing
and practicing physical distancing so we
can continue to bend the curve but we
are at a point of time where not
dissimilar to the announcement that was
made an hour so ago on the East Coast
that were beginning to socialize
conversations we've been having over the
course forth many days in the case of
the Oregon and Washington governor into
the beginning of last week where we
began a process of establishing more
formally what it would look like and how
we could begin the process of the kind
of incremental release of the stay at
home orders that advance the fundamental
principle of keeping people healthy
keeping people safe using science to
guide our decision-making not political
pressure and continuing to do what we
can to share our best practices and
share our results a bit differently I
can't them to document here's the yeah
and here here yeah look I'm not a
governor I don't know what that
responsibilities I don't know what but
but I also worry and maybe on I'm I want
to be careful with the way I say this I
worry that doctors and sciences know
their [ __ ] and we have to be guided by
science and the virus but sometimes my
feeling is doctors and scientists have
to look at worst-case scenario the told
another job and they're off
their projections are go back and listen
to the projections they had in this
verse it yeah so look at those these
guys that you're listening to look at
the projection well but they're over
there so it's not they're not even in
the same ballpark how far off this so so
their their job is to warn bring out
[ __ ] one of the powers that be that this
could be very bad I have to yeah now
that the thing is we also know the
doctors tend to be it's there in their
nature to be very cautious like a doctor
is not gonna tell you to box if I say
don't go to my doctor I go I put on
headgear and I box with the head he's
gonna go a lot of times doctors gonna go
what are you out of your [ __ ] mind
you're gonna get a concussion is bad for
you I'm not saying it's the same thing
I'm just saying sometimes I worry that
in the future if only doctors are
predicting this stuff there's got to be
a dance there's got to be a balance I
think I I don't know though I'm not
epidemiologist I'm not a [ __ ]
scientist so I don't want to I don't
know I don't [ __ ] a good mouth were
the originally projections yes no no I
mean pouchy they're so far off yeah now
that a lot of that might be because the
social distancing that we practicing you
know and and and and I do understand
that the idea is if we if we do this
right now we won't have to have we won't
have these flare-ups and then have to
stop everything after that I just don't
think even the flare-ups are gonna be to
be sure he and Ron you mean like the flu
the this flare field flute it's seasonal
and it's gonna be herd mentality yeah so
people are gonna get it I mean yeah yeah
the immunity and then it's gonna shorten
Troy shorten I just don't think that a
viable solution for these things is mass
shut downs we have to come up with a
more creative way to do it I don't I'm
afraid that we I worry that our economy
can't afford this and can't handle it so
we have to be we have to figure out a
way to be more creative how do we do
that
so the desert I fingered me around
60,000 originally predicted two million
yeah yeah yeah well they didn't know
they just a lot of it was uncertainty
this was a new virus but it just shows
you how out there oh my god worst case
scenario then they blast it out and the
traditional media goes to million people
about to die get ready shut everything
down so this like oh [ __ ] and I shut
down now for ridging and went hey sixty
thousand people you know died from this
virus Peter went that's terrible we
should shut down the economy for this
though right sixty thousand how many
people died in car wreck today how many
people died from pneumonia how many
people relax this one is the the
environment has taken a big old break
mother nature's like you can see the
Himalayas for the first time in like
five decades in India I mean crazy [ __ ]
right so the environment has taken a
serious thing but I also would say this
this has been a very good dry run for
when we do have a pandemic that actually
is truly deadly and kills two million
three million people that's just nothing
go after old people that goes bad for
everybody and that dad that's so this
has been a very good dry run we got
caught with our pants down and hopefully
we learn from this
we can be way better prepared that's
what I'll say because O'Brien's getting
himself a well solar power six seven
freezers full of hunted meat lots of
guns and I you probably won't be alive
when that next one here I state to be
shitty but come on hey when the real one
hits hey man you know how long you think
I'm gonna live how old are you know 53
but you up 40 years left probably right
yeah 93 just my genetics
yeah it's me I mean the last 20 in me a
disaster but so yeah 20 solid years left
many strong years no where did you meet
about me 30 no papa
mom you're 85 out of my mom are [ __ ]
fully full held you down 80 they're
killing it playing golf tennis knock off
I mean that golf and skiing that last
enemy left I see for you yeah last yeah
30 well yeah a good run 30 though not
bad 30 years mean you I got mono 30 even
my mom the other day was like I mean you
know how much longer do you want is even
it easy now I'm starting a guy like I'm
kind of tired of a lot of [ __ ] that's
what my grandma said when she when she
was I getting older she's like I'm just
ready Bren
see I'm tired I've had a good run she's
like what I mean what else just wake up
in the same [ __ ] every day I'm gonna
meditate I'm gonna get into the if lotus
position and just [ __ ] leave my money
I'm gonna go in my car probably when I'm
older up I have a four-door Bentley i'ma
buy a bamboo snake was this oh it's
called Bamboula yeah boom yeah boom
terrible I know
imma buy ya boom and release it in my
bed got one Viper that's someone that
died I guess that short fat thick snake
you might have to bite you in the neck
you know how to Cleopatra died by snake
yeah on the on the legs all right an ass
on the leg though when there was just a
cobra guess I believe she held it to her
neck let it bite you right in that
[ __ ] neck ah ah damn you're going
quick huh huh
all right give some current offense did
it go okay so
kaida on instagram wants you guys to
react to the singer jojo's IG live
here's the dojo though
young hit huh okay this is honor IG
video thought she was dead no she was
not she had some issues with her record
label so she couldn't release any meds
we're ready mm-hmm
check it out well damn Joe why she's
doing it for Calvin Klein honey
yeah she had a nip slip in five super
hot she's not letting you slow her down
she's been on live every day since then
it's just like this here's the thing
those are nice let me be a really super
liberal for a second oh she dies for a
guy take his shirt off and a girl can't
take her shirt off why is that
considered indecent for real that's a
hard argument for me I mean I don't want
women walking with her tits why not men
can't you know I'm saying though I get
it dude but also chilly a hard argument
but I would how do you write that in the
wall like why are women's to sexualized
because we suck them yeah you know we
and we [ __ ] up cuz guys want to gab
boon to sleep you got great tits but but
at the end of the day if what men can
take their shirt off and show their tits
there'd be a hundred car accidents every
sigh understand that's not really a law
you can't be like well cause guys you're
too horny you know what I mean no that
is a law I understand but like same
thing when we can't walk around in
thongs but that's actually they can on
the beach you can wear a [ __ ] song
you know I'm saying you can you know I'm
saying so men we have to cover our
genitals and and then there are rules
like you can be nude in San Francisco
but you can't be aroused you can't have
a hard-on
Oh another time we saw that short fat
dude yeah with this dick yeah hold on
and you have to have yeah nudists you're
going to they walk jobs somebody close
this guy was just walking down the
street with his dick down he had a weird
body the three-piece set just bunched up
in the ring I did an Instagram thing
with Tariq we were we were on we're at
the pier where everybody is and a guy
well why do of course with a briefcase
walks by us completely there's nobody
doing that now I see black mm on his way
to work what a shitty body and shitty -
I'm not mad at Joe just hit though
it's really nice what do you think if
girls actually okay first do you think
if girls were allowed to show their tits
they would they matter they might not I
just don't know how you write in a law
that men can and women can't because we
are is a really sexualized breast but
not every culture hasn't does not every
culture does so in certain parts of
Africa certain indigenous cultures they
didn't you know a woman can walk around
with her and in Europe certainly most of
Europe and especially in Spain and Italy
and France you go au naturale
so women go walk around without tops man
listen I'm just got trying to see girls
with the tits out Brian and in Sweden
all in Norway it's law for a reason do
is you're afraid of what that your gob
hoon might get around oh my GAD boon
sniffing out all that you don't want to
be distracting no the minute I will say
this the minute you allowed women to do
that I think a lot of young women would
be walking around with very tantalizing
it'd be like the girls with the greatest
would have like they'd put like a little
scotch tape on their maybe I think rape
would go through the roof that's
something you do one more people like
run up and grab no I would imagine you
always take that risk when your elbows
women do that when they have their asses
out did something happen to her though
in this or no no some a fan just
submitted this and wanted you guys there
god bless you fan like that's a nice
thing we would get used to it I think we
would treat it hey like I do when I give
it up dude it's aren't coming out no no
because we'd get used to it we would get
like late when you go to a club and
women are really scantily clad look at
women dressing like clubs man minute
club and pay yeah but but like you can
see it if you got over there wearing
almost nothing and it's it's arousing
but guys aren't raping them they are
though they are the drug in them now are
now are they oh yeah yeah the tits
aren't coming out bright what else you
got I don't know ok so last week Tyler
Perry went out of his way to pay for all
of the grocery bills during the hours
that are for specifically the elderly
and the immune compromised in his
hometown of Atlanta as well as New
Orleans oh he paid all the bills at 73
grocery stores for the elders and that's
so cool hey
quick that's an idea not that I care is
Tyler Perry gay I think so right thank
you yeah there's another way he's
awesome I don't think he is the other
guy the other bless you guys know
something we don't know is he married
let me see I thought believe he's gay
can I see what he's saying here okay
I'll check for the yeah yeah nineteen
movies dressed as a woman
that doesn't make you gay though makes
you a crossdresser yeah I'm surprised
she still has a job did she hate on Kobe
Bryant Romare that it was her she wasn't
hating but she's great she's asked about
like the day after he died with that
basketball player yeah [ __ ] [ __ ]
this was no this is great
hey I'd bet I'd get my last dollar he's
gay that's a gay man I love you look
that up chin I love him too now I don't
give a flying [ __ ] but my gaydar is
pretty on his partners Jolie love you'll
see her could be a beard situation right
oh well okay John Lennon was married in
asketh Oh what John Lennon I'm not sorry
uh Elton John what Elton John was made
and had kids come on I don't believe
this true
oh he's guys girl there's another one ah
Ricky Martin right
oh yeah he's straight he's straight
Ricky Ricky I know he Martin's gay Tyler
Perry straight he's a big straight man
you don't do that many movies dressed up
as a woman like but that's his mom if
you're making that much money who's this
girl this is different girls there's two
different ones in these first one was
hotter
yeah the town is ridiculous I like the
other one you like the one with the bags
like this um right her really I like
that curly hair
well she's yeah look at her I like his
white tuxedo she's pretty whatever
they're all cute oh oh I know her you do
what else you got my power you don't
know her okay yesterday there was a
hashtag trending on Twitter about caught
I forgot what the hashtag was but
essentially there was a health care
expert that came out and
that he predicts concerts won't come
back until the fall of 2021 and people
were freaking out again these are these
guys they get attention by saying this
stuff might be we're talking about it I
don't think so no he's saying smaller
stuff will probably start up again
pretty soon but bigger concerts and
arena arena events are gonna be probably
2021 they say not to count on a football
season no they don't this thing's almost
season's happening who told you that
I've heard it from no Trump had a call
who told you that
Trump Patterson now Trump had a call
with all the leading men of all the all
the pro legal the big sports for good
news yeah and the ones the one they said
that's gonna be fine yeah football those
are things that should matter we'll see
I think the virus is gonna dictate that
you know I think I think that we we
don't know yet we don't know yet
football I I know I know what the I know
what the commissioner and Trump said
though I love your confidence and I love
your attitude because I really do and I
appreciate it and I want up and I'm with
you I believe I'm right with you on it
I love I love it I'm just whatever I got
a feeling where I'm just like I don't
know I I'm not worried about football
and the NBA is gonna start up in June
it's a lot of people in one room right
the NBA yes in June there's no way June
there's no way you're not a bad yes what
do you want that you think in June that
there be an NBA season the hellstorm
June and they're gonna let that many
people in no there's no pigeon play
without yet though totally in that case
yes
I just mean III just mean are you gonna
have stadium full of people when is that
all I'm saying the NFL season is gonna
start watch it no no no question just
don't don't expect I just meant you're
not gonna have stadium full of people I
mean I hope we do it I think by August
they would I think by August they well I
hope so okay I guess they will I really
do yeah I guarantee the season starts on
time but as far as the seasons the fans
being full I don't know how this is a
[ __ ] distant memory bro I really do
I'm so over the [ __ ] everybody had we
had another month
yeah one more month what is it do what
you just saying like Texas and certain
places are gonna slowly start opening
and within the week right
Texas kinetic that's what Gavin Newsome
things what you saying he's like like
other states
Washington's open Texas open today
Connecticut New York epicenters opening
things I love it
you guys are talking about a bet um
which reminded me you you were gonna get
a tattoo right but I'm still see a
tattoo yes that was years ago dude yeah
I mean you're supposed to get us out to
you now right oh why a panther aligns I
don't know because it just shows I beat
Corona
let's stop I beat this whole Corona
think you're gonna get a panther with
wings with wings just up like in a
traditional Panther head sure with the
wings of the Hat wings out of the head
so the wings will grow out of his ears
well no it's gonna be like behind them
behind him yeah wait what kind of wings
bat wings are no like no like
traditional like wings like a tradition
a Marik in traditional tattooing sure
they're gonna love it
well I'm not gonna love it I really hate
I'm gonna get on Thursday okay where are
you gonna get that tattoo what do you
mean where are you gonna get on my phone
I'm on your forearm yeah on your forearm
look for you feel you need another why
not okay but the problem is when you get
a tattoo it's why knots not the best
answer right maybe you know I'm saying
no I don't do you know how many tattoos
I have yeah but what would the Panther
you do to identify with Panthers and in
soaring Panther I like what they
represent which is what you don't I
don't know how an anti Corona hurry it's
the logo for anti Corona I didn't know
that oh it's a huge movement I did not
so Panthers let's fly
groaning groaning I flap away see if
there any Panthers with make sure that
bread is not oh no I like no I've
already gone over with my tattoo artists
right Hey Oh whoopsie Daisy I'm getting
what some like that right you sort the
hit scholarships but that be the area
we're in the area no we're not no that
one looks bad
okay but what type in type in
traditional Panther head save species
though wing Panther I mean that's in the
ballpark guy that's a maze with wings
are just pictured you know they're not
gonna have wings wings now I do when you
were in the shower or whenever you came
with this idea did you look at your farm
ago I need a panther there you go with
wings did you add the wing there you go
I'm gonna add the wings there it's more
like that right there not so colorful
yeah now that could be a mound line but
I'm gonna go with Panther but it's black
well Matt lines aren't black black no I
don't have any its mouth no I don't want
let's try a bit hole need a boon I'd
like you to get I got boom that's cool I
am just getting stakes though dude a gap
boon going down here's four arm that
would be cool as [ __ ] and that design
show let's see the one with the Sun it's
almost like a Japanese huh you'd be more
like that I know but that's not good
can I say I've got a Viper tattoo gaboon
viper tattoo there's even no gambling by
pretend promise there is there's right
snake tattoos oh it sounds cheats that's
good yeah you gotta get it better back
but that's cool as [ __ ] like I have
Celeste hey oh oh yeah let me see that
this one Wow all of them chin gets all
the cabins not bad Brandon and there's a
lot of gab boon tattoos that's that
gaboon viper dude look at the one on his
leg it's a movement man I like to decide
I have to say I actually like the design
like snake eagle be about a gap don't
don't snakes represent evil don't they
in the Bible the devil that's a
different kind of snake that I got one
Viper yeah but all snakes are evil you
know well
there's something cool about an evil
snake you know it's not evil a panther
with wings because it's the is the face
of anti Corona I didn't know it helps me
to wear a mask will have a panther with
right right right no no I understand
you think that's cooler than a gaboon
Ono see the yellow one that's what it's
gonna be like put wings out the sides
I'm pretty excited about it's happening
Thursday at 11 a.m. in Hollywood
Brian weren't you supposed to get a
tattoo for a fight Brian I was was well
I just don't know what to get did he get
boom talking all that [ __ ] get an extra
chin chin what's getting that now I do
you want to go night to town all right
do you have other tattoos I got one got
one in Ireland with Mia me Jay and him
to think that yeah I just would get it
if you could carve something really cool
for me to get where would I get it we
all want to go on together no what are
you talking about just get a pigeon a
small pigeon on the inside of your arm I
don't want it
why your pigeon I'm not a pigeon or a
clown because your rings a clown a clown
is good Oh
or maybe just wrinkles tattoo get breaks
[Music]
how about a young black guy
how about some tits just on the inside
your for I'm just a girl with huge tits
just effigy of a gene well that's not
really doing it you can put tits tattoos
let's see if I put 10 sucking dick
tattoos of tits yeah well no it's all
yes yeah apparently forget oh wow look
at the hog on that one with the girls
squeezing her tits together you see once
how much it did oh I know that girl
she's a [ __ ] hey dude I'm sick you
saying you know no you know no of her
that kids got a dick on them too
while she looks tiny though to haters
you also has a very flat ass
look at her [ __ ] up look at her
despite her web tips yeah that's too
much hmm yeah they get Boone yeah she
does for a living there she is there to
shake ass got ones that are all the tit
that are all tatted she's got that's her
with a tit job oh wow she looks great
yeah she's got a lot of work done is
that the same girl
all right Inc you see the one tits that
are covered in tattoos chin that are
covered in Tennessee this one's only
yeah those look at those knockers we get
hair I give those colored knockers those
are wrinkles bro yes sir wrinkles
damn it's a lot of work she's got a
panther that's a tiger don't Tiger Tiger
why it's grabbing her nipple it's weird
when you yes it is it's called the snap
milf scroll back it says this [ __ ] has
massive tits and lots of sexy down there
go down there that one on the court left
left-hand side yeah holy that's the same
one yes not it's grabbing the nipple oh
yeah congratulations
Thunder mega porn cough she said that
she's committed to her tits dude I think
it's sexy when girls have neck tattoos
they're sexy enough to pull it off and a
nose piercing right there big fan of
tats and that's it's a girl they're all
that girl they're holding on to her
ankles hmm you talked about the one with
the dick in her butt let's do flexible
though pictures we're gonna take a
couple of pictures of you here on a
white surface
all right strange world what else good
next events so a NASCAR driver was
caught saying the n-word problem with
live on Twitch and I'll show you some
play anywhere yeah you'll hear him in
the background then you hear this voice
sound like say like hey dude you're
you're on you
people can hear you hold on hold on
isn't this is volume last time I've
heard this it's always want which to get
you can hear me hey
Wow
well he was kind of popping to everyone
but
if we heard that
yeah him and I got PewDiePie
he also slipped then or before - yeah
yeah each other he's uh yeah they're
calling do you want a black guy that
word it's like it's like yeah he says to
his friend how some guys say bro almost
but also with the horrid our I know a
lot of guys who says I don't do that I
don't tell me guys who say that but
they're not racist at all yeah it's just
like it's me that's the other day and
like he was saying it I was like my
friends who will text it to me
yeah like yo ninja what's happening like
yeah all right well yeah yeah and
they're not prejudiced yeah I don't
think this guy's racist price shot lose
his job
no very sensible shouldn't do it yeah
hopefully yeah and you as I know this
but the Twitter CEO Jack Dorsey donating
a billion dollars you didn't know that
and that's like he he's compared it to
all the money huh he has three point
something million so he's giving away a
good chunk of his money him you don't
need that much for sure but that's
that's a really huge donation who I'm
[ __ ] impressed with that guy can do no
wrong [ __ ] off
holy [ __ ] you're on must is worth thirty
two billion dollars um I question that
number I question that number what
because there's a lot of government
subsidy involved as debt I don't
Tesla wasn't doing as well maybe now
total just killed it wasn't for a while
if any be honest I don't know but she's
worth at least a billion 10 billion
dollars Brian I don't know I don't know
about that
it depends on what you mean by worth
like like the company itself and then
how much debt is he got there's a lot of
[ __ ] that goes into that those numbers
are you don't he's worth billion dollars
those those numbers has thrown around
and depending on what you mean by worth
is he have access to that money what
kind of debt you were to sell his
company he would make billions and
billions of dollars and he owns that
company he would make billions billions
dollars unless he to in order to run
that company he has a lot of debt so
that there's a big difference I don't
know how much how much all these
companies also have large debt sheets so
depends he also makes a ton of money he
also puts a lot into his company
yeah but again 33rd the pride gone what
what Tesla is worth and few were to sell
them get that my brand you get that
money probably thirty two billion
dollars are you [ __ ] kidding me I
didn't know that oh here's the other
thing dude yeah if he's worth that much
[ __ ] dude he created [ __ ] a PayPal
and sold that for me so did but he did
that with Peter Thiel who I think is
worth about three billion so it wasn't
like they made they made a lot of money
on it
billions Brian yeah but three billion
not thirty two thirty two is crazy yeah
but he got 1.5 billion from that 1.5
billion not thirty two billion s history
yeah yeah but he took that money and
then went and built Tesla the guy's
worth billions of dollars be yeah yes
guaranteed Wow yes miss added more than
seventeen billion to his net worth just
this year more than any other
billionaire in the world but to put that
in perspective he has made 500 million a
day since January or 20 million an hour
he's still think he's worth a bill I
don't know I don't know well this I
don't believe this I don't know I mean
these aren't a hundred on this from each
in Tesla CEO Elon Musk got 4.5 billion
richer overnight click on that why - you
see it all the time
what's he making so much money from well
I mean the Tesla came back from from
being you know but you thinking Tesla's
his only business ninety percent of the
company stock worth thirty four million
shares saw the value of this holdings
jump by four point five billion so he
could sell those shares at any moment
that's amazing wow that's quite good
[ __ ] great car man great great car and
he defied everybody - everybody was like
no you know email do it for all this
reason you get government subsidies and
all that and then at one point the
company was bust because they were so in
debt and everything else and he was like
yeah whatever you know you even me as a
testimony they're like you may not have
you know the company may not exist
and some people buy it out of song God
Bezos says hold my [ __ ] money cuz he's
worth so much more money that is crazy
money he's always been a visionary he
doesn't you know people like that are
just like gee yeah what'd you say oh my
god especially he's making money right
now
during this pandemic you got more than
ever mmm-hmm so you can't fix that
sniper I though what else she got gin yo
let's do well take a look this is funny
some kid in lockdown asked us the older
brother to cut his hair like an old man
that's me that [ __ ] hilarious so cute
oh I try to get my son to shave his head
but he's like nah yeah but there he is
you just did it with his board he was
bored he wants older brother who's 7 to
cut his hair so I took his dad's pipe
version cut his hair it's like an old
man I'm gonna stick to my long hair dude
you are are you do so I don't want to
grow it to here do something with it
why let's give it a little out of
product and keep it like that no you
know no I just put it back so doesn't
flare out I like it I'm just kidding
it's getting a little annoying under the
bike helmet well keep it like that all
I've ever wanted was feet 30 pounds
heavier with muscle I have a bigger
frame and have hair like that you're a
piece of [ __ ] and so I did and I want
darker skin actually you do have a lot
of things because I I don't like not I
don't like burning I'd like you consider
you pretty tan though I know but you can
be in the Sun with no I never wear
sunscreen
yeah no problem I've always said
sunscreens for [ __ ] yep it's the
Samoan and Mexican that you have in you
and then and then the and in the area of
the thick hair you want my hair yeah bad
dude if I could donate here to you and
give you some up top I don't like I
should have embraced my thin boy might
you know being a skinny man and instead
I always tried to be him you're not
scaler you're actually you're I don't
know have a good Jill watch me and I
yeah I watched him me in the episode of
Sex in the City it was on it just should
have a little watch it yeah and I was
like 36 at a time
and I just I hate myself like I hate
everything I probably did a good job and
inner winner but I was like I cannot
watch myself I just was I I cringe I'm
just gonna go and I was I think you know
looking guy I was 36 you know give
yourself a long accomplice there but
yeah oh you look really good but I just
can't a thing over and I look good no I
look sleazy is what I mean I look sleazy
you plan a character though yeah just
full of [ __ ] and I was working so hard
of being a good actor good yeah hey
click on the bottom left far bottom left
will your Brian's eyes there are you
high or not a man is a [ __ ] dime
piece yeah she looks great gorgeous you
look like complete [ __ ] I look like a
[ __ ] you look like your tool you look
like you can't my tool well just there
you do you're not a tool just there you
look like one you here looks better now
than that alright what else we got um
one more just to look at Drake's house
have you guys seen this head strakes how
he shot a music video from it how did he
have you seen it looks like a instead of
a cluttering quarantines and he releases
the fireworks at the end it's crazy so
that's the running joke too that a lot
of people foresee looks like a nice club
or karaoke studio all the different
rooms
let me guess people are hating on it I
mean of course something's in my style
that's for sure
that's thing because it's really like
out there's eccentric you know it looks
pretty I think it was awesome like this
looks super cool looks super sweet yeah
he did an interview from there yeah they
got a great joke piano yeah everything
looks cool look at that this is real
sick how sick is that
yeah that's pretty cool the outsiders
yeah this is this pool area that's cool
yeah
yeah and that looks like a karaoke room
you know much fucking's going on that
place I would have mad nightmares some
right right now check out a stairwell
he's doing did you see - dak Prescott
Prescott the starting quarterback for
the Cowboys got in trouble just do a
party like last night
oh my god Oh basketball court
what look at the couch - so the boys can
chill while you're playing you know I
mean I dance it's like a hundred million
dollar mansion in Toronto yeah that's
not cheap look at this thing that's his
bathroom but there's so many details to
it yeah the outside it looks super sick
- here's the thing you'll sell it and
make it my good kitchen
look how giant that island is around
there it's a lot going on it doesn't
seem very homey no it doesn't she's very
yeah it doesn't it's not it doesn't seem
cozy the outside yeah oh my goodness
that's it
is it this one here that's it Jesus
mansion me the biggest music artist in
the world
I expect that yeah yeah that's pretty
much it that's pretty cool man
Oh have you seen his son yes he's
gorgeous so he looks just like his mom
he's it's crazy how good you wouldn't
but you wouldn't think Drake's kid looks
this way yeah look far-left pick that's
the picture he posted look at that kid
oh how cute is that
ah little blond afro and blue eyes looks
just like Drake's mom he's so cute
Drake's mom yeah
Drake's mom looks exactly like that I
know it's gonna show the song well they
were hooking up and she got pregnant but
no it's just this yeah she does have the
curls oh yeah you're right Jewish right
yeah Jewish mom mom super light she's
Jewish
yeah it's Jewish from Black Bolt school
drink I know I think she's just Jewish
uh the dad his dad super black she's uh
she's Jewish upset this kid mm-hmm he
got all the height
from his dad how tall is he no not that
tall six one it's a six year yeah so
she's she's three six that eight kids
that's it all right II can't give me
dates when this is over
I know I want to start booking I'm
calling Justin you're this optimistic
I'm [ __ ] I got dates booked dude if
you're calling now it's a little late
what are your dates I'm in Tacoma and
last weekend in June and I got my kind
of suit you should for real I know just
get the [ __ ] down I would do it why not
I should just be your feature and I'm
not joking get out of here why just come
to come I mean like all the time
no I'm sitting oh yeah we should be a
two-man show it should be I'll just come
and [ __ ] it'll be fun
no what the [ __ ] get out right yeah
Mikey hey any please ya don't have to
just kidding
don't have to just give me some whiskey
hang out deal done something really not
joking I didn't mean either let's do it
we have nothing to do dude I want our
might be doing extra finding the kids
during this shutdown just for the
shutdown we're like doing 3t fat K's a
week Monday Wednesday Fridays I think
it's a good idea to be a good idea I
think don't we do I think the listeners
would like it should we do it yes you
win this Friday see our dough is a bonus
firing the kid yeah yeah people watch it
if they don't we'll never do it again
yeah they do we'll keep doing it let's
do that and let's bring some let's bring
some of our whiskey hey which one's come
today or tomorrow okay let's go yeah I
need a 12 top aside to deal with him hey
so so Friday right I want to do some
drinking okay you can just guess we do
it later on this afternoon get drunk as
[ __ ] yeah we could skunk drunk a couple
skunk ease I was gonna have this killer
ass oh come on
but he only wants to do it electronic
nope he doesn't want be too big of a
[ __ ] to come the studio I can't have
you on the show
we put him on put him on
we could we could FaceTime on an iPad
right there funny good let's see what
happens be funny
let's 100% put a body there can we do
that and put his head let's do that and
see how it works with that let that's
the only way let's see if we can be
creative with how we we Skype people in
shufti on ipad Jeff body to set it on
top of I have a good iPad chin probably
has a body you guys do you guys have any
of those bodies like those training
training dummy bodies they could bring
no no well it's gonna be tough to get a
body yeah we can make one we just hire a
fact I hope or we just can't just sit
over there and they just touch it but we
got a beanbag let's get a beanbag
yeah well bonus episode this Friday this
is that it this the fun kid route